right well zombies have invaded Tivoli
Village and Rocky is inside Fear Factory
to check out their new home enter if you
dare
all right we've seen his Museum of
monsters we've seen the ax Kingdom and
now we've combined it all for Fear
Factory here at Tivoli Village thank you
Dirk forget another experience here in
town thank you for coming and joining us
yeah we love Halloween so we thought
we'd combine all of our attractions and
we added zombie escape which is a highly
themed interactive zombie experience and
we're taking kind of
okay so it's interactive it's definitely
interactive live actors animatronics and
it's all zombie themed okay I've Loved
zombie movies since I was a kid so this
was just a natural progression of you
know taking that uh to another level
favorite zombie movie
probably not a living dead still have to
be the classic one yeah okay that
started it all now I'm seeing
I'm stances that really separates you
from everyone else oh my gosh we
actually we do make a lot of the props
ourselves and then we buy a lot of props
and then we modify them so that they fit
properly for all of our experiences
we're headed to the zombie swamp okay
oh my gosh okay this is called the laser
effect oh yep got the laser effect going
and the smoke machines that create that
kind of a zombie effect with the swamp
yeah you go first
okay we've got bright colors
this is the toxic waste area so
everything is black light UV lighting so
uh everything is glowing uh kind of like
a toxic waste that's a human okay okay
and what I love about this one is it's
kind of a Ode to Vegas with the neon
absolutely it's a bit it's a Vegas strip
with zombies so yeah we have to we we
created all of this to make it more
colorful as well this is great now how
can people enter into the the Zombie
World with the entry process deer
Factory is brought to you by stride
education and if you have kids between
the ages of 8 and 18 you can come in and
experience one of these attractions for
free okay and we are also benefiting the
American Foundation For Suicide
Prevention as well so we've got a good
cause got to help some people out as
well so bring the family down get a good
scare or a good cause Dirk thank you
thank you you guys